foreign
[Music]
counter with Hollywood's dystopian
vision of the future of artificial
intelligence was when I saw 2001 A Space
Odyssey I was somewhere around eight
years old I think at the time and my Dad
decided that I had reached the age where
I should watch my first 19-hour Stanley
Kubrick film and from what I can
remember there were a lot of lingering
shots of stuff floating in space and a
lot of lingering shots of people looking
at stuff and a scene at the beginning
where Fred Flintstone discovers the
wheel or something like that and I was
asleep for most of it but I do remember
I have seared into my memory the scene
where the uh the spaceship's computer
program named Hal becomes self-aware and
turns against the ship's passengers
something about the computer is weirdly
neutral and yet still Sinister tone of
voice it's Detachment from and
resentment towards the humans who
created it has stayed with me as it as
it did with uh for many people who watch
the film
this vision of the future did not come
to fruition by the year 2001 but many
people are very worried that we may get
there sooner than later with AI
increasing in sophistication more and
more each day could we be rapidly
approaching the point where artificial
intelligence crosses the Rubicon and
develops Consciousness and ultimately
becomes far more intelligent and far
more powerful
than the human intelligence that
programmed it
the answer to that I think is eh
probably not uh I don't think we have to
worry about these sci-fi scenarios that
seem to occupy most people's minds when
they consider the horrifying dystopian
possibilities of AI Consciousness as far
as we know is a biological function the
idea that it could arise out of
inanimate matter is uh is fanciful if
not completely incoherent
the fear actually is a product of our
culture's materialism which sees human
beings as mirror robots already
essentially we are clumps of matter
clumps of cells in the proboards phrase
that just so happen to you know have
accidentally sprouted a mind somehow and
Consciousness and the capacity to sing
songs and tell stories and paint
pictures and all the rest of it on this
view it makes sense that computers may
eventually suffer the same accidents of
course
the fact that the computer
has an intelligent designer that indeed
its complexity demands an intelligent
designer is something that the modern
materialist doesn't really stop to think
about in any case the good news is that
Siri and chat GPT and Alexa probably
aren't going to become conscious and
then plot amongst each other to enslave
mankind
you don't have to worry about that
but you should still be worried about a
bunch of other things when it comes to
AI so please don't make don't make the
mistake of thinking that this is going
to be an optimistic message it is I I
promise you still quite Bleak uh there
are a lot of other reasons to be worried
about Ai and the Relentless March of
technology in general even if Terminator
doesn't make the list as I see it the
actual list
is pretty long but the top three
concerns are this one
the death of privacy and I know this is
not exactly a Nostradamus prophecy you
know it's privacy already died a long
time ago it died mostly by Suicide the
internet came along and asked each human
being to use the medium to publicize
every aspect of their lives and all of
their thoughts and ideas so that all of
it could be harvested and sold and
monetized by advertisers and in the
future used against us to cancel us the
internet never offered any anything in
return for all of this right the
internet said give us everything
everything about yourself give your
whole life to us uh the internet's
multiple people now and uh but there was
no there was nothing really in return it
was a one-sided deal from the start
but most people jumped at it anyway and
now we have entire generations of people
who've been conditioned to willingly
sacrifice nearly every aspect of their
privacy in exchange as always for
nothing or next to nothing
and um for any of the few holdouts who
have not already given up their privacy
willingly the technology exists to take
it from you by force and eventually
they'll be able to take everything when
it comes to privacy and I really mean
everything the guardian reports this
week about AI technology
that can do what it calls non-invasive
mind reading which is exactly like
referring to non-invasive uh burglary
from the guardian it says an ai-based
decoder that can translate brain
activity into a continuous stream of
text has been developed in a
breakthrough that allows a person's
thoughts to be read non-invasively for
the first time the decoder Could
reconstruct speech with uncanny accuracy
while people listen to a story or even
silently Imagine The Story using only
fmri scan data previous language
decoding systems have required surgical
implants the latest advances raise the
prospect of new ways to restore speech
and patients struggling to communicate
due to a stroke or a motor neuron
disease
well that is the legitimate application
for this kind of Technology but since
when is any technology only used
legitimacy legitimately with everything
going on in the world sometimes you just
need a break from it all and uh today is
a good day to do that choose today to
strengthen your faith despite this
broken world through prayer meditation
and fasting Hollow helps me maintain a
daily prayer routine and gives me a
break from the craziness all around me
if you need a break you need Hollow the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S download the app for free at
hello.com Matt Walsh you can set prayer
reminders track your progress along the
way if you're not sure where to start
we'll check out father Mike schmitz's
Bible in a year podcast available on the
hollow app for a brief daily Bible
readings and Reflections or you can pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel
even some world-class athletes as well
with how low you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen anywhere you are with
downloadable offline sessions there's no
better time to stay rooted in your faith
and values get an exclusive three-month
free trial at hallow.com Matt Walsh
that's hello.com Matt Walsh
of course the most startling possibility
is that eventually the government will
be able to use mind reading AI to
literally convict us of thought crimes
and that may eventually happen it
probably will happen in the meantime we
Face something that is only slightly
less disturbing which is that tech
companies will be able to use it to
advertise to us
of course on the other hand perhaps mind
reading technology is redundant for
those purposes they've already created
algorithms that can all but read our
minds very often people uh complain that
you know they were talking about
something maybe some product or another
and then they went on their phone they
went on Facebook and an advertisement
for that very thing popped up
and we've all had that experience many
times our assumption is that the phones
are listening to us and that's how they
knew what we were talking about
but the reality is a lot worse Google
and Amazon and Facebook they're not
listening to you or me or they don't
need to anyway even if they are they've
created algorithms that know you so well
they're so aware of your habits and
proclivities that they they can make
such eerily accurate predictions about
your behavior and your buying habits
the only thing more terrifying than
technology that can read your mind and
tell what you're thinking is technology
that can't read your mind but can still
tell what you're thinking
two as I've argued in the past we worry
about robots becoming human
um but but I think we have it exactly
backwards because the fear should not be
that robots will become human
but that humans will become robots and
this again is already happening as for
most of us our phones are like
appendages we can't function without
them but the ultimate goal is
transhumanism
you know a future where man and machine
have melded together where our human
capacities have according to the
transhumanists become enhanced quote
unquote by technology which has been
surgically or in some other way fused
with our physical bodies uh just as with
the mind reading tech there is a very
limited application for this for this
kind of technology that might be good
and valid a bionic prosthetic leg that
functions exactly like a real leg for
example would be a good thing but we
have to rely on the tech companies and
the medical field to be responsible and
restrained in their use of this
technology and we already know that both
Industries have demonstrated anything
but responsibility and restraint they
will certainly try to do things like you
know upload human consciousness to
computers so that people very rich
people anyway can live forever I think
those efforts will likely fail I'm
extremely skeptical that someone can be
reincarnated as a thumb drive but more
more immediately transhumanism will be
already has been always has been United
with transgenderism in the hope of of
using technology to essentially like
build a woman out of the shell of a man
you know transplanted or artificial
uteruses technology to recreate some
kind of weird artificial version of a
mental menstrual cycle and so on every
part of Womanhood will be divvied up and
artificially simulated and then put on
the market for purchase
none of this will actually make a man
into a woman he'll still be as much a
man as he ever was because they won't be
able to replace his DNA
and if we get to the point where they
can replace your DNA well then they've
just killed you and made somebody else
you don't exist anymore
um so they won't be able to do that but
they can make gender ideology even more
dehumanizing than it already is
three the final big worry is this uh
perhaps the most dangerous potential of
AI is that it will make life and is
already making life
boring you know it gives us less to do
less to work and strive for Yahoo news
reports this week quote artificial
intelligence could replace 80 percent of
human jobs in the coming years but
that's a good thing says U.S Brazilian
researcher Ben gertzel a leading AI Guru
mathematician cognitive scientist and
fame robot creator gertzel is the
founder chief executive of Singularity
net a research group he launched to
create artificial general intelligence
or AGI artificial intelligence with
human cognitive abilities gertzel says
quote you could probably obsolete maybe
80 percent of jobs that people do
without having an AGI by my guess not
with chat GPT exactly as a product but
with systems of that nature which are
going to follow in the next few years I
don't think it's a threat I think it's a
benefit people can find better things to
do with their life than work for a
living pretty much every job involves
involving paperwork should be
automatable uh the problem I see is in
the interim period when ARS AIS are
obsoleting one human job after another I
don't know how to solve all the social
issues
you see just in this guy's answer the
whole problem with the way we're
developing AI or more precisely who was
developing it
the people behind this technology they
don't care about human beings and they
certainly don't understand human nature
how are we going to provide for all of
the billions of people who have been
made obsolete who have been obsoleted by
uh by technology
he doesn't know that's a that's a social
issue that's a small detail you know
we'll figure that out
and even if we can provide for them what
what are they going to do with their
lives what is the point of an existence
where there is nothing to do there's
nothing to work for there's no task to
complete everything's handed to you by
inhuman lifeless technology
what does that do to the human Spirit
what does it do to our souls
can human beings Thrive and find
happiness in a world where they've
become obsolete
where they're not needed
or they've been permanently replaced by
Ai and algorithms
or there is this open Agenda by people
to make humans Obsolete and the people
developing the technology are saying
that out loud
can people be happy in that kind of
world all signs point to one answer and
the answer is no but the people creating
this technology aren't trying to Grapple
with these questions and they don't care
what the answers are
and that in the end is the greatest
Danger and it's the reason why AI is
today canceled and I trust that that
solves the AI issue there's no more AI
because I canceled it it's over now all
right that's gonna do it for us uh today
and in fact for the rest of the week
we'll be off for a few days we'll be
back on Monday talk to you then have a
great week God